10个短线 9个骗
一个在训练
在骗你上车啊
买盘左边我挂满满的
你是不是想上车
会
那都骗你的啊
那是让它往下砍啊
卖盘挂满满的
你就觉得上面压力好大
骗你的啊
它是往上拉啊
对啊 那都骗你的啊
反正不难啊
反过来想就好了啊
对啊 当你很恐惧的时候
又买点到了
当你想说
哇 我还要再赚个380
卖点到了
就这么简单
欢迎收听今天的
让Pro吉的来
不晓得大家在开始入股市的时候
抱持什么样的想法呢?
很多人以为投资等于快速致富
但其实大多数的人在股市里面赚不到钱
甚至还会赔钱
到底问题是出在哪里?
今天很开心可以邀请到一位传奇投资人
他曾经从10万翻到1000万
也曾经经历三次的资产归零
他是怎么翻身的呢?
让我们欢迎全正小哥!
嗨!大家好!我来了!
欢迎小哥
小哥我有一个问题想要问
就是很多人觉得说刚开始投资股市
就是要短时间翻倍
这是真的吗
短时间翻倍我觉得难度是比较高
因为通常你要短时间翻倍
你一定要开杠杆
开杠杆的话你可能要用全赠啊 用期货啊
当你开杠杆的时候
你的获利是有机会翻倍的
但是你的风险也大幅的增加
别人可能在赔5% 10%
你开杠杆可能一倍赔50%
所以这个杠杆是两面刃
所以你要为了追求投资翻倍
可能你得付出一些代价
这个在一个大多头的时候
例如说2021年的航运股的行情
还有之前的AI的行情
还有最近有些BVU的行情
那这些行情
你假如搭配一些权证的工具的话
它的确是有机会让你翻倍的
小哥因为你刚刚一直有提到
就是权证的部分
但其实大多数人在一开始
听到全证的时候就会觉得很复杂
就是全证到底是什么啊
全证它是一个衍生性金融商品
它是经由这个 经由设计
这全证它有到期日
履业价 行资比例
那由这些组合成的一个商品
据来说它可能例如说
大力光它可能会设计一个
我的履业价3000块
那行资比例0.1
到期日可能是7月1號
那這個商品組合出來之後
它會有一個叫隱含波動率
就我們把這三個參數輸進去
再加一個隱含波動率的參數
然後再經由電腦的一個
BS公司的換算
它就會有一個理論價
然後券商它就可以按這個理論價去造勢
那券商可以賺取它的時間價值
那投資人可以獲得它的槓桿
就這樣
聽起來非常複雜嘛
实际上买全证
最重要就是你要挑一个好的发行商
那目前为止我觉得元大发行商还不错
那有些发行商不好
不好的发行商
他会在隐含波动率动手脚
隐含波动率贵呢 全证就贵
隐含波动率便宜 全证就便宜
那隐含波动率是券商他自己可以调控的
他可以在你买的时候很贵
在你想卖的时候他把它往下降
对 他可以从中
从中获取他不该获取的利润
那很多券商都是靠
调整影韩波动率为生的
所以我们都说买权证
就是除非你对这样的股票非常有把握
那不然你绝不能说我买权证去等
等这个行情发生
你一定要有这个行情
然后去买权证
感觉里面充满着各种不同的陷阱
对 它本来就有陷阱
权证本来就有陷阱
因为那陷阱就是券商获利的来源
你想想看权证发言商
他要养这么多交易员
然后他也要上缴证交所的发行费用
你买全证事实上就是
你跟发行商借钱嘛
那跟发行商借钱他要拿多少利息
就取决于他要用什么手段来拿取这些利息
那所以当你买全证
你买了行情都没动
你会赔钱
你会赔时间价值嘛
那行情有动了你才有机会赚钱
所以我们都说
你平常没事去买全证的
你的获胜机率可能就二三十%而已
因为呢
盘整的时候你赔钱
敌的时候你也赔钱
你只有大涨的时候才会赚
有可能小涨还是赔钱
所以买全资的事实上有蛮多美账的
感觉全资也不太适合小资组
我觉得小资组它有两个方法
就是期货跟全资
期货相对公平点
很多这种小资组爆发上去的
我们看到很多
有的是从全资
那比较大部分都是从期货
因为期货的杠杆也蛮大的
例如说像之前伪创的行情
从30块到160
那你假如买期货 你买了
然后涨上去之后
涨上去它的期货的保证金呢
你又可以继续用
你还不用卖掉
所以涨了之后
你又有保证金出来 你又继续压
那压了之后
又有保证金出来 你又继续压
那个翻倍是很惊人的
哇
所以你可以找一个有大行情的股票
那期货呢 一直压
那这种是比较有机会翻好多倍
那偷偷问一下
小哥之前就是靠权证
我之前是靠全證
从10万到千万
我那时候就是都买全證
因为那时候是全證的造势新制
那全證的造势新制跟现在完全不能比
我那年是2009年
它的全證跟现在的全證品质差太多了
因为造势新制出来
投资人也不熟
那连发行商也不熟
那导致发行商想说
这新制出来
我们在发行全證的时候
他们有个隐含波动率
他们那时候都卖得很便宜
超便宜
就跟2008年台北市的房价
在那当时你会觉得
台北市房价看起来也很便宜
从现在找到去看
那时候全镇的隐含波动率就这么便宜
现在台北市的房价可能一瓶200万
当时可能一瓶三四十万
那个隐含波动率就像这样子
以前的隐含波动率可能卖三四十
那现在有的隐含波动率卖200
那就卖的很贵
当全镇隐含波动率很高的时候
你要买全镇获利
就会相对困难很多
就像房子一样
你现在买200万房子
你说你要获利
那变得很难了
因为到底谁要接你的盘
一样啊
那买全镇
那鸭波动物很贵鸭波动物很贵会给你买的就是发行商那发行商有的卖给你之后它会往下调那往下调之后呢就代表说你买这样的股票只要没有行钱或小涨的行钱
或涨的速度不够快的行钱
都容易赔钱
但我们那年代不是啊
我们那年代卖得很便宜啊
股票只要有个2% 3%
那全镇的报酬率都很高
因为隐含波动力便宜
它的杠杆就大
隐含波动力跟杠杆是反向的
影韩波动率低 杠杆就会高
那听起来有点像超超板
对 超超板
所以我们那年代影韩波动率都很便宜
因为刚发行
所以那时候台积电的影韩波动率
都在20附近
影韩波动率便宜
这个又快到期的话
它的杠杆就很高
它杠杆有时候到10、56倍
那10、56倍
10、56倍你只要一根涨停
你的全真就翻倍了
就翻倍 那时候才7%
你这样想吗
7% 7乘以15倍
就105%
那我们这算起来是105%
那事实上全镇它是非线性的
所以实际上它可能到了140-150%
那有时候两根涨停 哇 才六倍
你看那个后面翘奖很快
它是一个曲线
全镇有趣的就在这个曲线
所以那时候这个玩的方法很简单
就是你就去买
比较高杠杆的强势股 压就对了
每天都有很多档强势股
再分三一点买
那基本上在当时刚好
2009年也是个大行情
那时候从4000点到6000点
哇
你觉得涨2000点不多
涨2000点涨50%啊
个股翻了
对啊
所以那时候赚钱就是那个时机
那现在你叫我买全赠
从10万到千我觉得非常困难
很困难啊
那么好的全赠也买不到
所以现在其实更需要的就是技术
对 需要技术
那或者你可以用期货
因为现在全镇的杠杆
有的都没那么高了
那期货的杠杆
至少都还有五六七倍
或者像买美债期货
美债有期货
美债期货是20倍
我这一两个月
美债期货也赚蛮多的
因为小哥你刚刚有提到说
就是现在有
之前有这么多只股票
就是有为你带来一些很好的报酬
那就是也很好奇
你有没有做过什么
就是比较后悔的
有有有有
像以前 我覺得我比較後悔的股票
大部分是我覺得
它怎麼可以漲這麼多而去放空
看也不會鬆一扛
看它不爽去空
這個新聞我覺得不大好
這個案例我們也講過很多次
就是如虹
之前如虹的本益比是三四十倍
那時候台積電十倍
我們都是做衣服的跟做晶圓代工的
怎麼本益比差這麼多 高這麼多
他认识我们护国神山
那时候卢宏多少
卢宏我记得好像300
他认识100
总觉得纺织股不应该享有
如此这么夸张的本益笔
然后就去空它
那时候对筹码还没有很详细研究
我不晓得筹码可以告诉我们
那个高低的点位在哪边
那只是纯粹从一个基本面角度去看
那这种去放空
我觉得犹太有执念
它是很危险的
还容易赔大钱
因为没那么高 对不对
没那么高你会怎么样
它越长你会空越多
你就堵它收敛
它假如真的没收敛
你后面你会收不了 就挺損
所以其实就是一个心态上面的问题
心态上面的问题
就是不要去设股票的上限
这股票人家坐在哪边 你哪知道
因为股票涨起来
它也不管这些基本面
那它只要管策码就好了
它只要策码就把这些空头卡到爆
那小哥其实我也还蛮好奇的
就是你觉得就是目前
你看下来有没有觉得就是
股市新手最常碰到的一些
比较容易犯的错误是什么
就是有没有什么投资的陷阱
是我们比较容易踩雷的
我觉得股市新手
最容易的就是最高啦
因为他常常会在一个
会在一个过往的情绪里面
然后犯下错误
据爱说他可能去买这张股票
20块买来赚钱
30块买来赚钱
到40块怎么样
把身家All in
因为他太有信心了
就刚好四五块就在高点
那跌到三四五块 变赔钱了
因为在上面他持有太大部位
不在上面他扩了太大杠杆
所以我觉得新手最容易犯的陷阱
就是他容易最高
容易相信一些这个坊间
一些人去诱使他买股票
他会说你看这样股票很好
你看我说的这是没错吧
那一定会赚到多少
那你假如去研究筹码
你就知道说哇
这地方是人家在出货的地方
那这种出货的地方
很多都是傻物会买进去的地方
例如说假设涨股票从10块涨到100块
这过程上他都不会买
他会觉得说涨太高 涨太高了
有天从100块跌到90块
他就进去买了
对
他觉得打折了嘛
打折了 他觉得这样股票100块一次会创高
那回想到90块我们就是要上车嘛 对不对
那结果一上车
他就开始买在山的右边嘛
因为股市是个造山运动
这傻物都会买在山的右边
人生的右边就看到傻物就开始大幅的买超
大不得进来
这不管之前的航运股
还有之前暴涨过的AI股
它很多形态都一样
就是Sanwon就买在这个下跌段
那我觉得Sanwon最常犯说就是这样
他不去研究筹码
那你会研究筹码你就知道说
这边是人家出货区
反弹是找空点
或反弹找卖点
也不会再去买
所以其实还是要了解那些
要了解筹码
每天光看数字要卖在最高点
那真的是要积很多因德
不然我觉得没那么容易
那我比较好奇的是
如果这样讲的话
是不是如果我今天要做投资
我就一定要每天定盘
但其实一般上班族
也没有那么多时间
就是关于这个
因为我们订阅的人数非常多
我们订阅人数是目前全台湾最多的
订阅人数多呢
我们就有几个研究筹码的面向
有的上班族他根本没有时间
那没有时间呢
我们就找一些比较适合他的方法
像有些退休的老师他跟我讲说
他看我的PP他就买债券他说他觉得我讲的很有道理我说债券波动很小债券波动大概就2、3%就一个月 一个月 2、3%分那长期而言
目前的债券也是在低档
然后他现在买的利息
算起来值利率有5、6%
那买债券他买的非常安心
他也不用看盘
所以退休组有退休组的方法
那假如是上班族你想说
我希望除了值利率以外
我看能不能赚到一点价差
那赚到价差呢
就是第一个我们去找
那个低档有分点大买的嘛
低档有分点大买100
赚到价差的机率就比较高
那我们再加上殖利率的筛选
你现在买了
那外面有涨 没关系啦
你至少有殖利率可以领
你至少固定配级可以领啦
反正这些股票它配级都不错
关键低档买高殖利率
它就选股的王道啦
那how to lose
怎么输啊 怎么输
跌了就值率变高 你就继续买
那涨了就是你有赚价差嘛
就这样而已
就这样
那只要这家公司不要倒就好了嘛
因为我们不是投国老师
我们没办法跟你讲说
多少钱买件 多少钱卖出
我们只不过是一个筹码的整理人
那最近我们的订阅还有一个特点
是我们有QA
QA每个人每天都可以问
小哥你这个 你觉得这张股票
你最近有没有看到什么样的筹码
我们都会再拿出筹码K线
然后把书彧给他看 就这样子
我们就给他看他看到的东西
那这些东西都不会骗人
我没办法骗你啊 对不对
我没办法骗你
那我觉得这个跟
跟投股老师就有很大不一样了
滑鼠他自己按的
然后我们只是分享这些大户
他最近的冲法状况怎么样
然后他自己再判断
他到底要不要下单
那我还想要问
就是其实在市场恐慌的时候
会是比较好的进场时候吗
對 例如說2022年的10月
那時候市場很恐慌到12000點
從18000到12000
那時候我們的訂閱
我們就特別寫了一篇
叫打造屬於自己的ETF
第一檔關鍵買高值利率
那時候我們叫做
打造自己的08888ETF
那個ETF號稱0888
那個文章還在
各位你現在可以回去看一堆翻倍
因為我們挑的方法很簡單
第一个 我们去看你公司附近的分点
要不要大买
那你股票不一定要做价差
你可以领股息
7%不香吗
香 叠下去8%香不香
超香 对不对 超级香
有很多股票在那时候都是低档
它殖余都很漂亮
又关键买 又7% 8%
你去去买 后面怎么样
后面等着涨上来
后面殖余剩下4% 5%的时候
你就殖余变丑了
知名變首代表你價差賺到了
所以那時候的股票一堆範圍
但還是很錯啊
因為你不知道它什麼時候
它還會被繼續往下跌
所以我說買股票一定要做價差嗎
你可以領利息啊
你現在進來買8%
你很錯啊
9%你錯不錯
9%你繼續買啊
對不對
你幹嘛一定要賣呢
分批買啊
你說你沒錢
沒錢就不要動了啊
你幹嘛砍呢
你砍得有比較好嗎
爸爸利息太多了
你看台北你買房子的租報酬率都1%
1%啊 對不對
你說啊因為房價會漲
我現在買房子
然後租人家1%後面會漲
最好是有人會跟你買
對不對 你買1%那誰要跟你買
你說在賣房子你說
我們這個租金投報率有0.5%
所以買房子都不怕了 對不對
買房子大家趨之落晤了
那買個股票8%也怕什麼
所以其實還是看籌碼
就是他其實籌碼好
就不怕它一直往下跌
不怕啊 往下跌再买啊
所以后来验证啊
那时候买的点
再往下的幅度都不大
顶多很多都
我觉得大部分都不到10%
有很多那时候都低点
那后面就涨上来
那为什么我们会很精准的
在那时候找到那个点
每天研究关键分点
发现最近关键分点买超多
而且以前关键分点
可能就是跌下来买一点
涨上来不卖
那不是 那时候是关键分点
都连续买
那我每天都念这一档
大家听久了
后面有的都两倍三倍这样
所以第一档关键也就是王道
就这样
因为这个方法我们用很多年了
所以一下我们订阅的旭月率非常高
93、94、95
很高耶
非常高
旭月率这么高就是因为它有用
它没用旭月率这么高
那他们可能都爱上我了
我每天一定要听我声音才能睡觉
每天一直赔钱一直听我声音
那不可能嘛 不可能的事情
他们一定从中有学到东西
他们才会序愿
那其实我觉得像在做投资的时候
就买股票什么的
其实都还是会有点小情绪在
就是有没有什么是
可以克服这种心理素质的
就是你研究筹码
研究筹码就不会有情绪了
大户买你就跟着卖
大户买就跟着买
你的情绪常常都是相反的
这个有人跟我讲
小哥我做当中做很烂
我每次买 买在高点
每次卖 卖在低点
我说你是天选之人
天选之人 你每次买都在高点
每次卖在低点
你不觉得你是天选之人吗
你下次反着做就好了
你每次要买按卖 要卖按卖就好了
你不是就每次都可以做到高低点了吗
对不对
因为你的情绪常常都是犯错的
所以你要做股票
常常是你要跟情绪为敌
主力10个有9个想要坑你
短线呢 十个短线九个骗
一个在训练
在骗你上车
所以在骗你上车
这个我们在地域上面也讲很多
所以要骗你上车很简单
我左边挂哒单 你就想上车
买盘左边我挂满满的
你就想上车
那都骗你的
那是让它往下砍
对
卖盘挂满满的
你就觉得 上面压力好大
骗你的
它是往上拉
对 那都骗你的
那不难
反过来想就好了
对啊 当你很恐惧的时候
又买点道了
当你想说我还要再赚个300%
卖点道了 就这么简单
好 那我还有一个问题想要问
就是小哥有没有什么是可以给年轻投资者的一些建议啊我觉得要多学习啦多看小哥的直播都看小哥的理财答案秀
你看久了你会很有感觉啦
像我们理财答案秀这些都免费的
理财答案秀有《歌有筹币报》一系列
你把它看完吗 免费的啊
不用钱 对不对
你看完之后你对股市就很有感觉
当你很有感觉
你又想要节省时间
这个研究筹码
有没有什么比较好的方法
那就订阅啊
订阅一个月才800%
对
800%
用年定来算的话
因为订阅会帮你整理筹码
那整理筹码
你再去选股票
就会相对比较简单
我觉得今天的内容真的非常的干活
然后也很谢谢小哥
有分享了很多关于投资上面
就是我们常会遇到的一些坑
然后还有简单的一些入门策略
还有如何打造就是投资的正确心态
我相信就是各位听众应该也瘦一两多
但其实就是我们大家都知道
就是投资这件事情其实不是一蹴可及的
其实真正的关键还是要有一套可以实行的学习计划
那这边最后呢
还是要特别再介绍一下
就是小哥现在在PressPlay上面也有开设
就是专属的订阅制课程
里面会手把手教大家如何挑选
然后还有规划投资的策略
还有一些及时的市场分析
让大家可以少走歪路不当股市韭菜
那也想要再请小哥在最后再自己推荐一下自己的
所以订阅制
好 那我们订阅制呢
我们每天呢我们会看一下大盘的状况
每天都有大盘走势啊
那你看最近的主力的买卖超啊
外资买卖超 投资买卖超
外资未平昌状况
傻估未平昌状况
那我每天呢我会跟各位讲说
我今天有当冲哪些股票
那是每天事后才讲的
我们事前不讲
因为事前讲会影响到行情
我们事后讲
那这事后讲一切合法合规
因为我事后告诉你
我今天做哪一档
那赚钱赔钱我都会跟你讲
你看久了你也可以猜得出来
我今天可能会做哪些股票
那我们里面还会
这个每天都会有十档
这个主投买跟主投卖的股票
因为主投买主投卖股票
假如是第一天买卖
那个都蛮有参考性的
因为投信第一天大买
很有可能他后面又继续买
那每天也还有这个关键买卖的股票
那你看一下关键间在买哪些股票
在买哪些股票
那假如第一档关键持续买的话
那都是一个不错的标的
那还有筹码好的标的
那筹码好的标的我们常会在标译上面写
筹码好的股票涨停
那这种股票呢就是
最近去你要设好你的停损点
因为筹码好的股票很多都标股
就是你下车时间你要自己掌握好
那还有一些全镇主力进出的状况
看看波澄全镇最近在买什么
那全镇主力进出状况
我们就可以看出来
它是隔日冲还是波段
那还有这个地板股
还有申报转让
那这些我觉得
这些对教育方面都非常有帮助
那这个是每天的固定的内容
那我们在假日的话
都会推这可转载观察的标的
那这些观察标的呢
是给老客户看
假如你连续订阅满两个月
或者是你是年订阅
符合资格的话
我们在周末呢
都会有一个专栏叫做可转载
那你可以从口转债里面看到有低档发债的
或者是高溢价的标的
或者是这个大量转换的标的
那这些标的我们都会整理
那我们还会整理低档进货股
高档出货股
让你看一下这些股票的形态
那这些老客户都看得到
那今天就真的非常的谢谢全盛小哥
今天来跟我们做分享
那关于
那关于就是全盛小哥的就是订阅制的话
我们也会放在就是节目的资讯栏里面
让大家可以直接点击
然后如果大家有兴趣的话
去订阅 去订阅
今天就谢谢小哥
好 谢谢
很多人都说
小哥你赚那么多了
为什么还要开订阅
老实说 活到了这个阶段
赚多赚少不是重点
而是寻找人生的成就感
而我开订阅最大的成就感
就是听到学员跟我说
股市不好
周遭亲友都赔钱
就他赚钱
这也是我开订阅最核心的教学理念
用小哥20多年的实战交易经验
帮助所有学院在空头时活下来
并且长期稳定获利
为了达成这个教学使命
我每天都很认真的准备教学订阅资料
例如开盘前
我会看美股台股等重大财经新闻
还会浏览试戳报价张述
借此观察主力心态
盘中则是会透过看盘软体
掌握个股、期货、权证、大盘、台子期走势
以及交易量能等资讯
收盘后,我大约会再花4个多小时
把盘中、盘后收集到的各种资料去无存经
制作成影音,搭配图文解说的方式
让学员下班后,可以很轻松地掌握关键分点
主力投信买卖超、权证资讯、地板股
申报短样章数
并从案例中学到实用的
当充以及短线交易技巧
我的订阅教学内容
不仅适合当充短线
果断投资人
也很适合存股的投资人
例如
我会传授如何在关键低档买
挑选出高值率存股标的
订阅我的专案
等于同时学到短线
以及长线的全方位投资技能
这样一来
更能从容面对诡谴多变的股票市场
提高胜率
我从2018年就在PPA开订阅专案
历经了股市多空循环
而且这么多年来
学员的蓄定率非常高
为了回馈学员
我会把学员的留言提问
录制成学员QA详解
帮忙解答疑惑
而且只要连续订阅满两个月
就免费赠送
价值3888元的
老客户精选密技与筹满研究专案
让学员可以做更进阶的学习
我是全正小哥
欢迎加入我的订阅行列